tell you warren buffett's secret to  finding good managers and partners in  the businesses he owns number one is you  need to look for somebody who's got high  energy number two is you need to find  somebody who has integrity third they  should be sharp as attack number four  they should have an owner's mindset  about all things related to the business  meaning they're thinking long term not  weekly or monthly or quarterly but what  is going to build enterprise value in  this thing and give us a sustainable  strategic advantage that will be able to  continue for years and years and years  that's how you find a good partner